Les députés du Rassemblement National,
décidément, n'aiment pas la République.
Non, vous n'aimez pas la République.
Vous n'aimez pas sa devise, liberté, égalité, fraternité.
Vous n'aimez pas sa promesse d'émancipation
qui fait que l'attachement à la nation,
c'est l'attachement à la patrie républicaine,
au fait d'appartenir à
cette communauté de destin où le peuple est souverain.
Non, vous n'aimez pas la République
en voulant imposer la préférence
France nationale dans le recrutement.
On voit là tout votre rance
xénophobie qui à chaque fois dicte vos amendements. Non,
cet amendement est totalement anticonstitutionnel,
cet amendement est 1 discrimination inacceptable.
J'espère qu'il fera le minimum de
voit et que jamais dans notre République
car sinon elle ne serait plus la République
et elle ne serait plus l'idéal de République sociale.
Jamais sa préférence nationale ne saurait être imposée
à nos concitoyens concitoyens.